évidemment cette actualité car la
mobilisation n'a pas touché que les
salariés les étudiants étaient également
mobilisés aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines
et les différents syndicats étudiants se
sont donné rendez-vous à la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour un départ
vers la manifestation à Paris les
mouvements des Jeunes Socialistes
l'Union des étudiants communistes et
lunettes étaient réunis on écoute tout
de suite Alexandre Netto président de
l'Unef à l'université de Versailles
50 on veut pas retourner en arrière tout
simplement on n'a pas envie non plus de
travailler plus pour gagner moins tout
simplement qu'à 10 ans on se bat contre
le CPE ce gouvernement était contre le
CPE et disons plus tard on ne peut en
CPE x 20 c'est hors de question du coup
aujourd'hui on se mobilise et dans la
durée on va faire monter la pression
chaque semaine le manifestation
manifestation partout en France jusqu'à
le retrait mais total de ce projet de
loi aujourd'hui on est entre 50 et 60 à
partir des Yvelines c'est très
encourageant ce que c'est la première
c'était les vacances pendant deux
semaines et pour autant on a réussi à
mobiliser 50 à 60 personnes qu'on va on
va rejoindre tous les autres qui sont
mobilisés à Paris et la prochaine date
de médiation c'est le 17 et je vous
promets qu'on se remet trois fois plus
que et une autre mobilisation générale
est prévue normalement le 31 mars
lunaire quant à elle appelle à une autre
journée d'action dans l'université le 17
mars